and that's why i'm going to direct this
verdict and find this here defend it
guilty
god aleister that was terrific terrific
bloody genius you're not going to top
that one wouldn't be the first time i've
had the clap
[Applause]
marina
you ghosted me well now i ghosted
everybody look i'm here on business
alistair pinch the after killed his wife
maybe he killed her maybe he didn't i
don't think he even knows the guy's a
blackout drunk i deplore drinking alone
so i have a devil
the network's got a lot riding on him mr
waldo you're looking to hire
i'm retired come on let me bring you
back into the real world what would i
even do with the money where's all your
stuff calm myself down to 100 things
and you kept that hat
what save detective will you return to
your mountain and leave me to the fates
will you stick around long enough to see
the police maybe get it right this time
[Music]
where did you come from welcome to
kindergartens of the rich and famous
death must have shot the hell out of
this place huh come meet me tonight we
can talk then
do you trust me why should i trust you
so anything you're not remembering
i had gotten married fathered children
had taken out mortgages and not
remembered
you do realize that everyone is sure you
did this
[Music]
oh god officer they're going to arrest
you go put some clothes on don't be
silly enough the network will adore me
in this wardrobe
anyway
if it's good enough for wacko jacko it's
good enough for me
can't you tell when a girl just wants to
have a drink with you
buckle up
[Music]
okay look i'm a pacifist and i refuse to
get involved
have you had enough
i've had enough
[Music]
[Music]
you